i also think of the bukowski
i returned to that there's a little clip
of him in an interview
saying that love is a
fog that dissipates with the
first light of reality or something like
that so basically emphasizing that it's
this very
very very fleeting thing that it's a
it's a it's a moments thing and then it
just
fades and everything else is uh is
something else so love is only a
temporary thing
which is interesting i think some people
say that's cynical
i don't know i don't know what to think
of it i think it's important to
understand
that everything is fleeting when you
don't put effort into it
almost everything will be fleeting if
you don't put effort into it most people
will get fat and lazy if you don't put
effort into something you're going to
not be
good at uh playing guitar or playing
bass you've got to put effort into it
the same thing goes for a relationship
that the the awesome part of it
that like love part that dies soon and
early on in a relationship
because it's so good that we think we
don't have to work
at it but you do you have to like keep
doing the things you got to keep things
new and crisp and fresh and you know
when you
when you different people probably feel
differently about this but like
i don't know you walk around your girl
and you start like farting and stuff
like that's when it all dies
yeah that's when it dies you know we're
all human beings we all
you know have you know we're all here
and our bodies working the same way but
like
you start to chip away at this like
beautiful thing
when you when you stop
when you buck conventional courtesy
and and things like that well take it
for granted basically take it for
granted yeah i mean it's the same thing
with life
uh it's like it's the same i'm a big fan
of meditating on
death that you could die today in the
same way you should meditate on like
this relationship could end today
this connection with another human could
be this is the last time you could uh
you could be interacting yeah and your
your chances of that increase when you
take it for granted and you on
people
but when you work at it the chances of
that decrease it's not
it's never going to be zero but it
decreases and
when you do that when you're the person
and you're you're trying to maintain
and you're trying to you know work at
the relationship you got to make sure
that both people are working at it
otherwise you're just a chump
you